let's go to the phones and see what's on
people's minds 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the
number listen for your area code I will
mention your area code when I'm putting
you on first caller is from the 504 area
code 504 go ahead hey how's it going
David it's Sean Morris from Alaska
cotton Channel all right god I was
really enjoying you guys hold music it
reminds me of the ice cave levels from
Final Fantasy 9 oh no probably you you
want me to put you back on hold no no no
that's okay I actually get cut off quite
a bit when I try to call so it's nice to
have gotten through good so I wanted to
ask you something and be warned I'm
gonna lead you into something and I
don't know whether or not all of the
Associated subjects are things that you
know YouTube likes as far as
monetization goes well my concern is not
so much the monetization but just
getting to the question directly so that
we can make sure everybody who's calling
it gets a shot so go ahead sure okay so
I've heard references to the Truman Show
and different things as far as the the
reality skewing that these Cambridge
analytics and Russian troll farms have
been doing to the United States and
other Western democracies for a number
of years and I was just wondering um how
far back do you think this goes do you
think this is just an election thing or
has your brain been going elsewhere and
further back and wondering like has this
been a 30 year campaign of deception
that has torn our society apart or is
this just an election by election thing
well the specific methods that Cambridge
analytic employed are only possible in
the era of social media and that level
of micro targeting so if the question is
have there been attempt to manipulate
public opinion dating back 30 years that
for the purposes of Elections the answer
is yes if the question is is micro
targeting on social networks what's been
used for 30 years I would say no because
that they weren't around that long right
i just remember encountering a lot of
Russian hackers in the like I used to be
friendly with them back in the early 90s
um AOL you know ever since the
Internet's been around it seems like
it's been used against its houses like I
was one of the people who was kind of
paranoid of our government you know went
down some of the wrong rabbit holes when
I was a teenager yeah but now I'm
starting to realize this is this is
really well-planned what they've been
doing to us and it goes down to like our
spiritual beliefs and everything how
does what Cambridge analytic it did
refer to spiritual it's just like it
well the level of sophistication that
these whistleblowers are mentioning it's
kind of the stuff that I've been talking
about on my channel for the past three
years now and Pyrrha chul I've been
seeing this well kind of like a
historical understanding of things and
just kind of how America kind of lost
its identity and lost its way as a
nation of refugees alright Sean thank
you for the call I'm not exactly sure
where we're going with it and I gotta
move on but I think maybe I have a
problem where my comprehension is sort
of compromised in some way I'm not sure